es un alimento cotidiano del que nadie
imaginaría prescindir en las calles de
yaundé el pan es un producto cada vez
más escaso y caro desde la explosión de
los precios del trigo pero aquí en los
hornos de esta panadería las nuevas
harinas podrían sustituir pronto al
trigo
para elaborar su pan el venía más ha
decidido recurrir a un nuevo ingrediente
la yuca mezclada aquí con harina de papa
dulce los tubérculos suelen consumirse
sin procesar en los platos tradicionales
de camerún la harina de papa dulce y de
yuca de manipularse fácilmente comunario
con tribe sin embargo estos panes tienen
la ventaja de que se pueden comer sin
problema por otro lado tenemos una
categoría de personas que no pueden
comer trigo porque el trigo tiene una
práctica línea llamada gluten la yuca
producida en camerún se utiliza como
alternativa al trigo importado hasta
entonces efe y sus jefes ni siquiera
habían pensado en ello pero el aumento
del precio de un saco de harina de trigo
lo cambió todo en pocos días pasó de 33
dólares a más de 40 dólares los 50 kilos
este aumento se debe a la caída de las
importaciones desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania de ahí la aparición de
estos nuevos panes de papa y yuca
estamos en fase experimental para ver
cómo funcionan
pero los comentarios que tenemos hasta
ahora son muy positivos
en la crisis ucraniana es un elemento
que nos ha impulsado
al ver la subida del trigo nos ha
empujado a acelerar la producción y el
uso de la harina típica local 2 dólares
por el pan de papa dulce un dólar por el
pan de yuca pesos muy superiores a los
del pan de trigo tradicional
pero la clientela está ahí seducida por
la idea de comer ingredientes locales me
parecen interesantes los panes hechos
con harina ecológica es bueno porque por
fin vamos a consumir productos locales
tenemos que empezar a consumir nuestros
propios productos
podría la yuca sustituir al trigo con el
tiempo algunos cultivadores sueñan con
ello este tubérculo es fácil de sembrar
en suelos pobres y es resistente al
calor tropical sin embargo es vulnerable
frente a ciertas enfermedades como el
mosaico de la yuca o la podredumbre
parda pueden diezmar toda la cosecha
para 22.000 hectáreas de tierra
cultivada camerún produce cada año unos
5 millones de toneladas de yuca en
enormes plantaciones como está a unos
100 kilómetros de la capital
también está hecho
donde discutimos
rosa lima cultiva del tubérculo en su
plantación de 140 hectáreas una
producción abundante en cada cosecha a
pesar de la falta de maquinaria agrícola
sofisticada considera que el aumento de
los precios del trigo es una bendición
para miles de agricultores como ella
y hay variedades que dan 30 toneladas
por hectárea y otras que dan 35
toneladas por hectárea a los productores
de yuca pueden satisfacer todo tipo de
demanda ya sea dentro del país en la
zona de la semac en áfrica o incluso en
óxido
siempre que el gobierno nos apoye en la
mecanización con la llegada de la guerra
a ucrania donde la harina de trigo ha
subido repentinamente al teléfono no
para de sonar todos los días
puede entregar dis toneladas 20
toneladas y todos podemos impulsar la
economía de camerún cultivando
el cultivo de yuca ya estaba en auge en
muchos países africanos antes de la
crisis ucraniana
y según la fao existe un riesgo de
agotamiento del suelo debido al
monocultivo intensivo pero estas
advertencias no han hecho decaer el
ánimo de los productores locales en esta
cooperativa que transforma decenas de
toneladas de yuca en harina el ritmo se
ha acelerado
el proceso de producción sigue siendo
casi totalmente manual y los productores
de yuca piden que la mecanización cambie
la escala de producción
por meses cuando procesamos tenemos de 5
a 3 toneladas de harina si tenemos
suficientes máquinas camerún no tendrá
problemas con la harina de yuca
sustituirá fácilmente el trigo porque
mucha gente lo entenderá y todos se
pasarán a la harina de yuca
[Música]
la yuca un ingrediente que esta otra
cooperativa pretende convertir en
esencial
la producción de anastasio baba ya está
agotada en camerún y en el extranjero
la harina de yuca se utiliza para hacer
pan pasteles buñuelos galletas e incluso
licores
mi yuca se come en todo el mundo la
harina se ve allí la suavidad que se ve
allí llega incluso a los estados
con el aumento de la demanda mundial los
países africanos productores de yuca que
ya cuentan con grandes multinacionales
de la alimentación entre sus clientes
pueden aspirar a conquistar nuevos
mercados